Hello everybody. My name is Markiplier
and welcome to Factorio.
Now this game came out recently
and it's actually very very confusing
I'll show you why..
AAAAHH What is all of this?!
WHAT AM I DOING? WHAT THE HELL?
OK, so this game is one that says it's infinitely scalable
which literally means the map that you're in
this, this area that we're in here... does not end
and there is no limit to the amount of resources
that you can get
which I have to do by slamming what I hope is a hammer
and not any part of me into these rocks
until I get the materials that I need
and when I do... that
I will be able to build things constantly and forever
expanding until it covers the entire world
and you can see the world map in factories
now I don't know how to play this game
so what you're going to see now
is a montage of me losing my goddamn mind
trying to figure this shit out
you got it?
OK, let's go! Cuz we got..
ONE?!?!  ONE IRON!?
FROM ALL OF THAT?! I WAS KILLING TIME!
Ok fine. This is going to be a b*tch
But we're gonna get there
Cuz I can get a furnace, I got a stone furnace
I'm gonna go from the Stone Age and the objective is to go to the MOON!
What is this? A cow?...
Oh... it's a mining drill
*gasp*THAT WOULD BE SO MUCH EASIER
THAN ME HITTING IT WITH MY D*CK
Oh, it's out of fuel.. How do I get fuel?
I can craft logistics, production...
Oh god ...
Oh god...
Oh, I don't know
I'll get a pickaxe. Cool. Did I...
y-yaaayy...
Oh god...
Oh. That's much easier!
I was hitting it with my d*ck
Oh, that's so much better
Also, I have a gun
so I'm assuming that I'm gonna get attacked at any moment
It's going to be bad
Everyone wants a piece of the Markimoo
Everyone wants some of my factories
Now I bet there's some guys out there watching this
or gals.. I'm not excluding.
That know how to play this game
and yes I'm going to be very bad at it
but by the time we get to the end of this very short episode
Imma be good at it
So you'll see...
Ehhh.. Oh! I can put wood?
I can put wood and then ... YEAHHHHH
That's how you do it!
Ok, that's good
Oh and I get more iron plate out of it
yesss I know how to play the GAME ♫
♫ I'm not that baaaad ♫
♫ I'm pretty baaad ♫
ok, so if I take some of the fuel back
I take these iron plates out
I put this fuel in th....
Wha - oooh, that's not what I wanted
Bam? AHHH
OOHH
EH
AH
Thank you
Oh you're delightful!
Oh cool!
AHH
Okay
we're getting it
we're getting there
okay
Stone, I need stone. Where's stone?!
Me am need rock. Me am need rock.
Is this rock?
Is this me am rock?
What is all that? Is that more iron?
Oh...
Oogh ugh me am get rock
to make steam engine and then get more mining drill
for me technology. unga bunga
me gonna get there eventually
with time!
Age of Empire style
God damn it, I'm back to hitting it with my d*ck
ok, so I can make ...
Three stone furnacii [furnace-eye]
I can... put...
no... wait no i can use these to then make...
iron gear?
How do I make an iron gear?
oohhh.. that's how i make an iron gear
ahhhh heheheheee
This is what I meant by infinite scalability
because things start to go up real quick
Is this coal or some- It is coal!
I need coal.
Ok, coal is gonna be good
because coal is a better fuel than whatever the hell
I was using before
so this is gonna be good
okay... we're gonna get there eventually
The thing about infinite scalability is that it starts out slow
SO STOP JUDGING ME!
This is really cool by the way. I will admit
I-It's kind of an interesting concept
Just like a vicious cycle that feeds itself endlessly
till the end of time
okay
now they're going
but what does that mean?
oh!
Oh they're full...
ooohhh
okay, so I need to ugh...
I need to find a way to guh...
I need more mughh
ok, so I gotta get a conveyer system
putting that over here but to do that i need more...
stuff...
tsk
uhhh
aaaahh there we go
okay
hohooohh
and then we dump these into...
*high speed gibberish*
ahhh that ain't working
okay, so what I've figured out thus far
but I haven't been able to piece it together exactly is..
I figured out how to make conveyer belts
and take the resources into... some other place
but I haven't figured out how to dump it into the furnace
which is my next goal
I will get this done though
I will..
AH! Burner inserter!
BURNER INSERTER!
BURNER BURNER BURNERBURNER INSERTER
BURNER IN-SER-TER
ah yes
Burner insertor
ah
Ah
we have ... found something
so, there's no fuel in either of these
I need more fuel
This needs fuel
I got fuel for it
boink
fuel for that!
that's good!
and then...
put fuel in here and we are in...
BUSINESS!
YES!
Does it...?
YES! THAT WORKS!
OH MY GOD IT WORKS IT WORKS
OH MY GOD IT WORKS
HOLY CRAP IT WORKS
I know this is tiny but this is a monumental thing for me
This works!
HOLY CRAP IT WORKS
THAT'S SO COOL!
Aw that's so cool
That may not seem cool to you guys
but this is so cool!
because this opens up so much more potential
There's so many things that I can do with this
This is insanity! It's so cool!
okay.. so if I ... do this
oh no wait. not that.
okay, so...
I need..
Oh! No I don't need to... ooh...
I don't even need to do that
I can just do this...
and flip it the other way
and just like that!
and then put fuel in these bad boys
put you in there
put you in... there
AND WE'RE IN BUSINESS
HOLY CRAP, WE'RE IN BUSINESS
THAT'S GOOD!
WHAT THE HELL?
SO COOL!
aw. so cool.
and then I can get inserters for getting coal ...
and putting coal in the coal machines and then...
Oh wow! I can put coal in the coal machine
in the mining machines and then the mining machines
will deliver coal to every other thing
Oh my god this takes so much planning!
God I need more time!
heheh
THIS IS SO COOL THOUGH
haaa cool
A boiler... ahhh
a boiler? what'd a boiler be for?
STEAM ENGINE, okay. POWER OUPUT!
Oh so I can make electricity, eh?
Alright, here's the deal. I'm starting to learn the game
I'm not quite at expert level yet
I don't have all the resources that I need
I need a lot more fuel
Fuel is the one thing that I need
so to power all of this
I need to figure out a better way to get power
than just putting things in
But until that time comes, I have these things
cranking out... like a boss
That should be turned the other way
There we go!
I have these things cranking out like a boss
getting me all the stone... and coal
that imma need for the future
and this is gonna keep going
this is just gonna keep doing this
Now I-I-I think I can have these dumping into... chests
I believe.. I'm pretty sure I can just have these...
NOPE! That's not how that works apparently
okayyyy
Maybe I need an inserter to put it in the chest
That would make sense
There we go. Yeah. Okay.  THERE WE GO!
and it's putting it in the chest. Niceee
but it needs more fuel
God everything needs fuel
woops
oh
crap! cra-crap crap. Everything's gone bad
Get more coal for it.
Fill this up with fuel cuz it's gonna run out
OH!
Since it's grabbing coal, is it
IT DID! IT GOT COAL FOR ITSELF BECAUSE ITS
GRABBING COAL
did it just get coal for itself?
he.. heahahaaha
Ah this is a very exciting time for me
OH SO EXCITING!
Okay, but I've got stone and I've got coal
and I kinda forgot about these bad boys
which probably ran out of fuel a long time ago
So I've got infinite source of..
fuel and then hopefully..
I've got a damn decent source of everything else
NOPE I DONT
Nyeh heh heh hyeh
It's out of fuel..
ALRIGHT! Coal production has INCREASED!
while stone production has stopped
but it's doing it. ITS DOING IT!
IT'S DOING THE THINGGG
IT'S DOING THE THING!
IT'S DOING THE THINGGGGG
HEHEHYAHAHAHAAA
yeah
ok, so there's another resource over here
c-copper.
ok, so copper's gotta be used for a whole bunch of other stuff
I'm just gonna dig some up by hand at first
and then I'm gonna get a
I'm gonna get a mining drill over here
cuz mining and automation
is all what this game is about!
ah ok
so.. I need to smelt the copper ...
and to do that
I think there was a larger copper deposit over here
yeah over here
I dunno if this is too far
and I believe that's
Oh that's oil
ooohh wonder what I can do with oil
Can't even mine that
Ok, so I was doing a little bit of preparing
in the background while I was assembling materials
What I have is I have copper going into a smelter
and I'm getting copper plates from that
which I'm gonna need for electronics
I've got coal being shunted into this thing at regular intervals
and I'm gonna make more of that soon
ah and I'm saving up stockpiling materials
So down the road I'll be able to just blast out
as much as possible which is gonna be very important
because the next step
everything is very disparate right now
everything is very, uh, far away from each other
what I'm gonna do in the next one
is I'm gonna make sure that everything flows
into each other
and figure out how to do that best
because I'm not entirely sure
how I can get everything
the fuel going into the right places
and the not fuel going into the right places
I'm not sure if I can do that just yet
but I do know that when this thing grabs coal
it will always grab enough coal for itself
and that's handy-dandy information
so I just need to get more
MORE
MORE CAPITALISM
I mean factories going
uh sorry
ok, so now that I have copper
I can actually make some of the cooler things
that I do need like
these science packs, these electronic circuits
I can make the offshore pump
the electric mining drill which sounds pretty cool
and actually consumes a lot less energy than the other one
it has more health and has bigger mining area?
Yeah way bigger mining area and a faster speed
that sounds cool! I want THAT!
HOW DO I GET THAT?! I WANT A LOT OF THAT
oooh can I get that?
and then I can make a lab which I'm assuming
is something that I actually need
so I'm gonna... wow...
ok so whenever I click on something bigger like a lab
it makes all the other materials first
and then it does that
so I was not actually able to do any of this
I clicked on this but
I don't even think it did anything because I did not have a lab yet
so once this is done and I do have a lab
We're probably gonna see something interesting happening
but probably not because I have no idea what I'm doing
Still! but this is so cool!
This is just really cool! It's just a giant world that you can
build that it builds itself
It's nuts
ah what do you got?
ooohh it needs actual power
Automation!
I need that!
Modules, science packs
So I need all the stuff then the next thing
that I'mma need is I'mma actually need power
so I'm going to need...
a boiler
and a steam engine
so I'mma build a boiler and a steam engine
I'mma build an offshore pump?
I don't even know what's that gonna do
I'mma build a bunch of pipe!
I dunno how to do this yet
pipe to ground? Sure, sounds good to me!
I don't know.... I don't know!
uuuhhh kay alright anyway
put fuel in it.. for some reason
get an offshor- OH! OH I CAN ZOOM OUT
OHHH MY GOD! I DID NOT KNOW THAT I CAN DO THAT
HOLY CRAP, it makes the world seem so much smaller
ok but we're gonna stay nice and tight right here
God that just changed everything
ok, so now we need to put the steam engine
Woah! that's bigger than I'd thought it'd be
k, so that's there
ummm, where did my pipes go?
I know I built pipes
k, offshore pump
k, so we're gonna pump this... hopefully
ok, so that's water
k, so that's definitely going in there
then we gotta put the boiler like right h- AH
AHA! ok!
Put the boiler there. Put the fuel in there
It's gonna boil up
and then steam would go into here? question mark?
there? YEAH!
OKAY!
ALRIGHT!?
I-Is that doing it correctly? I ...ooh
It's got water
It doesn't have enough steam?
No, it's got steam...
Agh, what am I missing? I'm missing something
The temperature is very low...
Oh! Oh! I just needed to connect the two of them
Ok, so that's now working. Yes!
and this is now powered!
Oh my god! Oh my god! I'm actually doing SCIENCEEE!
Now I'mma make these science packs
I dunno what they're gonna do
but I'm gonna shove them in
Oh.. it's not done yet okay I was wondering...
So I'm gonna shove these into here?
and they're going to do something?
okay?
I heard a sound
that's like the f-
OHHHHHH!
WHAAATTTTT?!
Alright, we got all the materials that we need
and we got the science lab going
which means that it's studying automation
but it's not quite there yet
I need more of these and I've got more of these
because I accidentally produced all of 'em
but it's gonna  do that
and I don't know what the modules do
but I imagine they probably make it go faster
and then this works towards automation
which is working currently
and then I'll get more things that I can make
BUT
I'm actually all out of time for this episode
I've been playing this game a long time
This is really, really ridiculously cool!
I wanna pick this game up again
so I'mma do another episode of it
I'm actually might do a few more episodes of it
just because it's really cool!
Th- I mean this is really REALLY COOL!
So I'm gonna give this a go
But thank you everybody so much for watching
Let me know what you think of this game in the comments below
I-I really wanna hear you guys' opinion on this
because this is nuts!
This is bonkers!
This is so cool and you can find the game..
It's on Steam I forget how much it costs
but there's a link in the description so...
thank you again everybody so much for watching
and as always, I will see you
IN THE NEXT VIDEO
Buh-Bye!